another day another state-of-the-art
result
in machine learning land on imagenet uh
this time coming from a thing called
lambda
resnets as you can see here it
outperforms
efficient nets and resnets right here
not only in terms of top one accuracy
but also in terms of the trade-off
between accuracy
and training time so here it says lambda
resnets are about 4.5
times faster than efficient nets and
substantially
improve the speed accuracy trade-off of
image classification models across
different scales so this is something
new that we have not seen in recent
times in recent times we've seen
like transformers take over image
classification and so on but it
it came either with um down sampling the
image like
this 16 by 16 patches and so on or just
throwing massive amounts of data at it
or massive amounts of compute
this paper here promises that they have
something that's more efficient
and it can reach a good accuracy
or for the same efficiency can reach
better accuracy
so today we're going to look at this
paper
lambda networks modeling long-range
interactions without attention
by anonymous authors it's under review
at
2021 i'm not going to de-anonymize
this paper well mostly because this one
is a bit harder and would require a bit
of research but also because i think
i've made my point i i
remain that double blind reviewing isn't
really
what it's set out to be in the ideal
case
but let's actually look at this paper
because the paper itself eats it's quite
hard to understand
and i still don't know if i understand
it correctly but
we'll just go through it and i will talk
about what i understand and then
we i guess we can have a discussion uh
for a discussion
always leave a comment if you want uh
join our discord
there are many many competent people
there that have
opinions um way better opinions than i
do
so all right so they say we present a
general framework for capturing
long-range interactions between an
input and structured contextual
information
e.g a pixel surrounded by other pixels
our method called the lambda layer
captures such interactions by
transforming available contexts into
linear function
termed lambdas and applying these linear
functions to each input
separately lambda layers are versatile
and may be implemented to model content
and position based interactions in
global local or mass context
so as you read this there are a number
of things right here that we are going
to blatantly disregard
while reading this paper so first of all
they present a general framework like
let's
like screw screw the general framework
they're going to apply this
to image classification we'll look at it
in the context of well first of of um
sequence classification and then of
image classification because it comes
out of the kind of transformer
area so then the transformers
classically have been applied to
sequence or set
classifications so we're going to look
at it in in that framework like
general framework blah blah right
okay so for capturing long-range
interactions between an
input and structure contextual
information eg
a pixel surrounded by other pixels okay
so when you hear again this long range
interactions
immediately you should think of
something like a transformer like an
attention mechanism
that that's exactly what they're going
for here and they're trying to frame
this into this
this like lambda layer the fact that we
built
a linear function termed lambdas from
lambda calculus
and we apply these linear functions to
each input
separately now any time you multiply a
matrix by a vector
that's what you're doing but the framing
here
is um and we'll see why the framing is
like this
but it sort of makes it
it introduces a new terminology
lambda laser versatile yada yada yada
yada
and the the tricky part or the important
part here is
as they bypass the need for expensive
attention maps
lambda layers can routinely be applied
to inputs of length in the thousandth
enabling their applications to long
sequences or high
resolution images the resulting neural
network architectures the
lambda networks are computationally
efficient and simple to implement using
direct calls
to operations available in modern neural
network
libraries okay so they have a bunch of
things here they
now get into the framework of okay it's
kind of like
attention but we do not need these
expensive attention maps and they're
going to show
why they do not need the attention maps
that an attention layer would compute
and we will look at what what's the
trade-off here like there's always a
trade-off
right the attention is kind of a very
very general
computational framework it's super
general it's like dynamic routing of
information
and they don't do that so we we're going
to see where the trade-off is
and the what they gain is of course if
they don't need to compute these
expensive
attention maps which no that the
limiting factor is memory
in transformers uh it's also a bit time
but we can just let it run for longer
but
memory we can't really just uh
wait long and then we get more memory we
have the memory that we have
so since they don't have that they can
take inputs and length of the thousands
you know they can apply these things to
high resolution images now we're going
to
see that applying these things to high
resolution images that is
let's say that is shaky uh
let me just say they can't do that
without
going to what's called local attention
and what i mean by this is so
attention mechanisms extremely briefly
extremely briefly
if you have a a sequence
and you transform it into another
sequence
that's what an attention mechanism is
for
the attention mechanism looks at a
looks at um from each
top part here it emits a query queue
wow that's a big thing each top part
emits a query queue
each bottom thing emits a key k and then
it builds
what's called an attention map so an
attention map in this case is just
a matrix a in this case a five by five
matrix and this matrix specifies how
each of the inputs is routed to the
outputs
so this five by five matrix as you can
see pretty clearly if i make
the sequence here longer then this like
one of the axis is going to get longer
and if i make this sequence longer the
other
axis is going to get longer and normally
or
in what's called self-attention these
sequences are
the same sequence so um you'll have
the sequence paying attention to itself
okay
and if you have an image what that means
in an image is that
so the image is already a matrix but
it's a
it's kind of a collection of pixels what
you would do is you would see
the image as a collection of as a
sequence of pixels
and then each pixel needs to attend
to each other pixel so you can see
pretty easily if the image is like
something like 200
by 200 that's what 40
000 so you'd have a
your matrix up here would be 40 000 by
000 which is impossible right so that's
that's the trouble here now people have
gotten around this
by doing what's called local attention
and local attention means like
you know you pixel you don't need to pay
attention to all of the other pixels
you actually only need to pay attention
to the pixels in your neighborhood
which is sort of it's a convolution
right a convolution is usually this but
local attention is a dynamic convolution
so usually in a convolution
you have a fixed convolutional kernel
local attention
is simply a dynamic convolutional kernel
like
global attention is a dynamic
feed-forward layer
instead of a fixed feed-forward layer
local attention is a dynamic
convolution instead of a fixed
convolution
they are going to do something similar
here
to process or high resolution images
they are going to restrict their context
to a local kind of local
field of view around the pixel that
they're interested in
so just so you don't get super hyped by
by the um by the abstract right here
so we'll go into what these lambda
layers do and i'm going to jump
a whole bunch of things in the paper uh
just so we get to the
kind of the meat of the thing so they
say
look at these images and we we just we
just set this right so
usually you have a you have for each
pixel
you wonder how should i transform this
to the next layer so you imagine your
neural network as having layer layer
layer layer layer
and in each time you can imagine you
have this image
and you want to transform it into like
an intermediate representation that's
still it still looks like an image maybe
has different number of channels and so
on
but and maybe it's a different
resolution but still you want to kind of
forward propagate this um image into
its intermediate representations and the
question is
for each location in the image so for
each pixel
how should i transform that particular
location into its next intermediate
representation that's what a neural
network does
in this in this framework what we
want to do is we want to look at this
pixel
and then say okay well we can't just
look at the pixel itself we
somehow need to look at all the other
pixels so
we know how to transform it because it's
going to be a really boring
neural network if we just look at each
pixel individually
so we're going to look at all the other
pixels in the picture
as we said it we're going to pay
attention to all the other pixels and
that determines how we should transform
the current
pixel into the next representation
that would be what they call a global
context
or global attention in the attention
framework however as
we already said here what we're going to
do is we're simply
around we're simply going to restrict
how far the pixel can look
at the other pixels um what they called
the
the local context so the pixels they're
going to be transformed into what's
called
queries like in the attention framework
the
uh context is it can be
something else but usually it's going to
be the same
as the input so the input is this
picture
and the context is also going to be the
but now we are going to additionally for
each location restrict the context
around that location so what local
attention would do
local attention would build for each
pixel an attention
map and the attention map as we said it
is going to define
how the pixel should pay attention to
all the surrounding pixels so you can
see right here this is the attention map
for this one pixel right so you can
imagine
that if i were to construct an attention
map for all
the pixels in the image you know it's
going to be
every pixel is going to have an
attention map like this telling it how
it should aggregate
all the pixels around itself and you can
easily see that
if we make the context as large as
the image itself that is going to give
us
uh each context map is going to be as
large as the image
and we need that for each pixel uh
so we're going to end up with if this is
if this is height and this is with we're
going to end up with height squared
width
squared memory requirements so the
difference in the lambda layers is that
the
lambda layers what they do is they take
the context
and they're going to abstract this
into a matrix they're going to summarize
the context first without looking at the
query okay
they're going to take the context and
make it into
this lower dimensional
linear function you can see from the
picture
that what they're trying to make sure
that you see is that
the left thing is basically restricted
to be
of the size that the it's pixel by pixel
while on the right side you have you're
going to have some freedom
over how you want to construct that
matrix and
they are going to abstract the context
into
a function and then they're simply going
to multiply this
by the query so the whole operation here
is going to be a linear function
as opposed to the attention operation
which is
you look at the interactions between
queries and keys and then you take a
softmax over that which makes it into a
non-linear function
this is going to be a linear function
okay so but the red rhetoric around this
you can already see
they say we abstract the context into a
linear function and then we apply
that linear function to each query
separately
the problem right here is that there is
one
context per query right as soon as you
go to the next
pixel like right here
your context is going to be is going to
be shifted
so it's not like if you had the global
context
right if you had the global context you
could simply compute this context
function
once and then um apply it to each
to each pixel individually that's going
to be
that would be the gain in let's say time
but here not so much so there
the trade-offs that they make in space
immediately result
in the in the breakdown of their
narrative
at least i feel like this now
how can you understand this just from
here before we go into the formula
again i would say we go back to kind of
the sequence
narrative okay so the sequence narrative
is the following we want to transform
the sequence into its next layer
representation in attention we
take a look here and we look at how does
this
pay attention to each of the inputs
right here depending on what the inputs
are
right we depending on what this query is
and depending on what the keys are here
so that's going to be really important
what we do here instead
in the london network is
we're going to take the context which is
this thing and now we're dealing with a
global context because
we don't uh so so we are closer to the
terminology
and we're going to summarize it we're
going to just summarize this
into a function so and the function is
represented by a matrix and the matrix
dimensions we can even choose how big
this matrix is
right we're just going to um summarize
the context without looking at the
queries and then the queries
without looking at the individual part
of the context like we don't do that
we simply take the queries and pull them
through
this function to get the next higher
level
representation right we take we take the
query
put it through the same function get the
higher level representation
so the the context is summarized into
one
single linear function that transforms
all queries
the same okay and we're
and it's not exactly uh what they do
like they have positional encodings and
so on
but in essence that's what they are
that's what they are advertising in the
first
place all right
so let's dive into the formula the
formulas are
fairly fairly complex i had a while
until i until i grasped all of this so
this is the first half
you can see right here that this
is the first half and then how you get
from here to the outputs that's
uh another set of equations
right here okay it's
again as i said it's it's fairly complex
and that's not all like there and there
then there is translation equivariance
then there is the convolutional
lambda and so on and the analysis
but let's break this down and see
where the lambda layer is different and
how it works
so we start out with the
input and the context right that is
that is here these are the inputs to the
lambda layer
x and c
now um keep in m first of all
okay let's let's build up a little
diagram over here we have
x and we have c coming in
and we'll annotate them with their
respective sizes
so x is n by d and c is m
by d so that's n by d
and m by d now
keep in mind okay that x and c
are often the same thing first of all
right or or is similar if c is
restricted and so on but
keep keep that in mind um so x and c are
often the same thing
n here is what would be referred to as
the input size
input size right and if n is equal
to m if x is equal to c
then the problem is going to be
whenever there is a term m by n
then that is going to be quadratic in
the input size and that is going to blow
up
so in terms of in when if this is an
image then this here is going to be
whatever
225 by 225
that's the image resolution that's
that's n
right n is this we're not talking d
is going to be the the channels so n
itself is going to be this giant number
so you can see that
n by m is going to be that
squared so whenever there's a term like
this
that's going to be a problem
so in attention what do we do in
attention let's make
a little um thing here in attention we
have
x and we have c this is n by d
this is m by d um
in attention what we're going to do is
we're going to transform
x by means of w
uh q but this is these are learnable
parameters the w
w q is d by k
so it transforms the
inputs into queries and the queries are
going to be n
one query per input uh
by the key dimension which is often
which is a parameter you can
choose then we're going to transform the
context
by means of wk which is
also d by k into the keys
which are now m by k sorry
and we're going to transform the c
into w
also into values and the values i mean
there there would be an additional
parameter of the value dimension but
very often
since the output dimension is going to
be d again
we'll just say this is m by d
sorry no this is let's call that
d by d which makes the values
m by d okay so these are now your
standard
attention parameters let's say
so you are going to take the queries and
the keys and you're going to multiply
them together
to get the attention map okay you can
see if you multiply those two things
together so
query you do query times key
transposed you get n
by m and you're going to soft max this
let's do it like a little sigma so which
is going to be
the normalized by m
and you're going to take the values and
calculate
the outputs y from this and the outputs
y are going to be
n by d
all right so you can see that the
non-linearity
is right here okay so the non-linearity
determines
how how do you aggregate the
context which is transformed into the
values linearly
how do you aggregate the context to the
output that's determined
by the non-linearity it's determined by
this attention map
and most notably you have this n by m
parameter right here this is a matrix
you have to construct
you can't get around it because you have
to apply a non-linearity to it
can't decompose it and that's the
problem
so now it's about to get complicated
really easy first of all we take the
inputs
and we're going to again apply a wq
that's d by k
to get the queries okay the queries are
going to be
n by k so far so good
so we got these um
we got the query as you can see right
here it's d by
k and the queries are constructed
like this now there's a there's a
mistake here authors
anonymous authors if you're looking this
is wrong
yes this should be something like n
by k okay not even u so
u here is like an inter dimension uh
parameter
this we're just going to scrap this this
is equal to one
for our purposes um
you can you know you can you can do all
the things with the with the you
equal to more stuff but we're just going
to leave it at one
if that's okay so
yeah yeah yeah scrap this um
all right so we got we got our queries
and you can see
keys and values just the same so we're
going to transform
the context into keys and values just
the same as
in attention let's quickly go over here
and do that
um here we're going to transform this
using w k which is
d by k and we're going to transform it
as well
using w v which is
d now they're they're going to say d by
v but we'll just always say d by d
and they are going to relax that later
on and so on but
yeah d by d so this gives you keys
and this gives you values and sorry
m by k and now
m by d
and now the um
the difference is is happening we're
getting to the positional embeddings
in a minute so now what we're going to
do
is we're going to apply a soft max to
the keys
just the keys okay so we're going to
take the keys
and we're going to do a soft max
operation
a long m so we'll maybe say along which
dimension here is a long m
along the m dimension okay so which
gives us
the key m by k now this is a little bit
weird why would we
apply the softmax to like an individual
thing and
we're going to see in a minute what that
does okay but
for now this simply it create we create
a key matrix the key matrix is
m by k so the and then we're going to
apply a soft max
over the m dimension and that means that
means we now have
k attention maps okay
we have k different attention maps over
m
inputs right and every time you make a
soft max you basically make a
distribution
and that defines how you aggregate
information
and so we have k different distributions
as
here you can see our attention map was
we had
n different attention maps
of size m and now we have k
different attention maps of size m this
is going to be the difference right
here it's not that attention vanishes in
this model
it's that the attention shifts where it
is
and you're going to see that quickly
when you look at
here this content contribution and
position
contribution is where we're going to now
multiply the keys by the values
and uh yeah the position we're going to
look in a minute but we're now going to
multiply the keys by the values so the
queries
are nowhere to be found and if we go
down here
you can see that we multiply the keys by
the values and then contract over
m so this is this is a a
a multiplication right here
so we're going to take the values
whoops d the values
and the keys and we're going to contract
over
m so in this case we'll simply do
whatever uh key key
like key transposed times v
maybe yeah that makes sense um
or the other way around no that that
sounds
sounds about right uh which gives
us what what do they call it i think
they call it
lambda this they call it lambda c
now we have to pay attention the c up
here
is going to be this is not a dimension
this is just the name
of this is lambda c which is going to be
of size k by d
okay
did we get this right this is going to
be of size
yes k by v in this case but k by d
in our case and contracting over m so
here you you see that it's kind of a
it's kind of
a tricky trick in here so this whole
thing
is sort of by itself and
it it does kind of an attention to
itself
it's the context summarizes itself and
you can see at the end
there is no more m so m
there is there's no more m m is vanished
from this
so we have summarized the context in
in and abstracted the m before we
ever had a chance to let it interact
with the
n and this is exactly
where um the this differs from attention
so the last step here is going to be
that we're going to take this uh
this lambda c and we're going to take
the queries and we're going to multiply
those together so this is simply a
linear
function right here this is a linear
function
we're doing q times lambda c
and that is going to give us our output
y
okay and y is going to be n by
d so each of the inputs
have this is each of the inputs next
layer representation so each of the
inputs next layer representation is
simply a linear function of its query
and its context and the context
is a summary of the context so what you
don't have
is fine-grained interaction between
position a transformer can say
well i am this pixel here and
i am green and you are this pixel
there and you are red
i am going to pay x amount of attention
to you this is no longer
and you this pixel here you are yellow
i'm going to pay
more attention to you you can't do that
the pixels in the context
they will go among themselves they will
decide okay
uh you're ad i'm yellow and so on uh how
much attention
should anyone be able to pay to the two
of us
they will put that into a summary vector
basically
and then the the query can only look at
that summary
vector and decide what it wants to do
with it
in essence i have a i have a multiple
frameworks of how you can
understand this
notably what you can understand this as
is the whole blue part here what it does
is it kind of constructs a vector space
okay it constructs a vector space of
k dimensions you can see here this k is
going to be very important
so it constructs a vector space of k not
of k
dimensions uh but it can yeah it's
like a subspace of k dimensions in the d
dimensional vector space so k is
usually pretty small so we're going to
have this
k subspace of k vectors
in the d dimensional space that is
constructed
and all the queries can do is they can
select
a point in that okay the
the meaning here is that the context
uh no let's let's go let's go a step
back and and
talk about this soft max operation
so it might be a bit weird to apply the
soft max
just to like a single matrix of keys
but that's not exactly what's happening
so in the attention what you'll have is
you'll have a
soft max over the queries times the keys
right and the both are computed
the queries are computed from the input
and the keys are computed from the input
and the the question is how how should
they
how should information be aggregated
from the values
that's determined by the two things okay
now in this case you might say well
it's just the keys that did decide so
there is no interaction but
there is um if you write the keys out
what the keys are the keys
are the context times this matrix wk
okay and what this
is now you can see this as the analog
to the one before so this here
is the input that's kind of like the
query matrix except the query matrix is
a linear transformation of the input but
it's sort of like it comes to the input
but this here is now no longer like the
key matrix from above this here is
actually fixed
so the keys in this
world are fixed how you can imagine that
is
each layer constructs a sort of like
a pseudo sequence a pseudo sequence
of k of k
different um of of size
k and what it first does is it kind of
summarizes the input sequence
we'll draw it we'll draw it like i drew
this before
so instead of transforming this sequence
into this sequence what it does is it
constructs a pseudo sequence
of let's say length 3 intermediate
and this pseudo sequence this
intermediate sequence
always always always has the same
um queries now okay you have to swap the
two
actually uh this this is kind of
like the keys this is like
the queries okay so
this sudo sequence always has the same
queries
and the the this this sequence down here
is now going to send information
to that pseudo sequence so this pseudo
sequence always aggregates information
in the same way
independent of what the input is okay
and
after and after so that's how it
aggregates the output
so no longer transforms this into
this upper sequence right here and then
of course
it does in the second step but this now
is just linear
so this here this part here
is a tension
and then this part here is linear this
is kind of reminiscent of
the lin former and so on that that kind
of cons
that project the sizes the intermediate
sizes of the sequence is down
it's just done in a different way is
that the attention is shifted
to this first part here and is
sort of fixed i don't even want to call
it attention
uh because it's kind of like fixed the
queries are always the same they are
learned
uh a bit like if you remember the detr
paper where we have learned queries so
what does this
mean um it means something
like you
each layer learns these different
dimensions that it
could that it it can
aggregate in the in the context so
this could be like color
so it it says this context
what what kind of uh what what or this
particular context element what kind of
a color does it have
it could be it could be higher level
features it could be
like is there is there give me the give
me
if there is a corner if if this is an
image
there's a corner or if this is a
sequence tell me
whether or not like what kind of word it
is tell me it's
it's um grammatical meaning i don't know
even though it's
grammatical meaning or it's label like
whether it's a noun or a verb
and here you you kind of get what i mean
that there
it constructs this space of properties
of the context elements and
each uh each query can then come
and basically decide how important
each query from up here can decide how
important each of these
is so this these blue
arrows here refer directly to
the pseudo sequence which is of length k
and then the query simply selects a
point
in this and um aggregates
information in that okay
i don't know if that's if that's
entirely clear
but the point is that the attention
operation is now shifted
to instead of transforming a sequence
into its higher representation it's
transforming it into kind of an
intermediary
pseudo sequence that has nothing to do
with the with the queries in question
uh is just dependent on the context
then the projection
to the next level representation where
the queries actually come in is simply
a linear operation constructs this kind
of subspace
um that has um
these axes and then
it uh in this subspace it's just a
linear operation to get to the
next layer okay so summarize the context
using attention
um so the the trick here is
you don't summarize the context into a
vector you actually summarize the
context
into a bunch of vectors so
the context can say my color is green
my my corneriness over the whole
like i got lots of corners
um and each of these each of these
properties is a vector as you can see
here
and then so maybe it's better
characterized as a list
a list of size k and each
entry in this list has a particular
meaning like color
and each one is a vector so the context
would be summarized into a collection of
k
vectors like this okay
so each context can have a different
collection of k vectors but still it's k
and then the query the query
can decide how it wants to aggregate how
important is color to me
it's like five five important color and
then she's like oh you're you're green
okay cool um how important
is corneriness to me eight okay cool
um the important part is what the query
cannot do
is it cannot go look it cannot
look at what the color is and then
decide how important it is
that's what makes it different from
attention so in attention
the query can see and it's like oh
you're green
well that's not that important to me the
query must decide
ah okay i myself am a
red pixel i'm going to pay 5 attention
to the color of
other pixels if i am yellow i'm going to
pay
seven attempts but it can't look at the
other pixels
because they're all summarized right
they can't go look at
all the other pixels you can only look
at the summary decide how
important is that so enough
ranting from me there is a second part
to this
which is the position encoding so they
have noticed
probably they've tried it like this and
this just doesn't doesn't work and
it shows in their evolutions what's
actually important is the
the additional positional encodings
and that's what they have right here so
the what they have now
is these encodings e and
e as you can see
right here e is already indexed by
n and m so e is going to be an
n by m by k tensor
you see the the inputs are n n by d
and m by d and e is going to be
n by m by k
now these are positional encodings so
what they do
is they are a fixed set of learn
parameters kind of like positional
encodings
in a transformer but
in a transformer it would simply be like
uh
m by k right that that's what what it
would be because you just put the
position encodings
onto the context or on the input in that
case it would be n by k
here we have an n by m by k so these are
actually
learned attention weights kind of
so these are going to be um
a matrix that is n
by m and is going to be a k dimensional
k uh dimensional vector for each so
each n by m pair has
a vector uh associated with it and
embedding
this kind of destroys the whole notion
of this summarizing the context first
right
because now we're building up basically
a learned attention map
a learned attention map the the
advantage here is that this thing is
learned this thing is not computed
it is learned per layer and um
it cannot be kind of changed from
example to example so that's the
difference between the attention map
so the stuff that is computed
dynamically
is not dependent on n by m
and the stuff that is n by m is not
computed dynamically and that has the
big advantage that if i have a batch
size in front then these things here are
all going to be
adding the batch size n by d by b
and by d by b while this thing
no b okay so there there
this thing is fixed and
all you have to do is you have to hold n
by m
once in memory and um
you don't have to hold it you don't have
to grow it with the batch size and
since we are reducing n and m anyway
because or
m at least because we are only paying
attention to local context
that's going to be feasible you can see
that you can't get around the fact
that you have to have these attention
maps and therefore you
probably in this framework can't get
around to the fact
that you have to have some sort of local
restriction because if it weren't for
that this thing right here
there is no n by m never ever an n by m
and therefore you don't have this giant
blow up
the attention mechanism is over m by k
as you can see here and as long as you
can keep k
small um that could actually
work with a global context okay
not with the position embedding and it
doesn't work without the position
embeddings
and they are not position embeddings
they are attention embeddings
okay let's or or or interaction
embeddings
uh to call them position embeddings
would be
a little bit a little bit i mean they
say it's a positional betting for their
relation n
to m it's important to note that these
again are not computed from the input
they're simply fixed they're simply say
if a pixel is on the top left and the
other pixel is on the bottom right
um then they are their
relation is given by this vector
right here okay so for each pair of
pixel there is an entry in this
matrix now how do we use
those kind of similar we just start down
here
we multiply them with the value
and you can see that you you will and
you contract over m
in subsequent equation where is it
right here you contract over m
uh which gives you this thing right here
which you can see there is
nothing here now there is an n here so
what you'll get naturally is
one positional embedding per input
so yeah as i said it sort of destroys
this
this notion of first summarizing the
context because now
it's uh it's on again so you're going to
take
the values and this thing
and you're going to compute from this
this
lambda p positional lambda
which is of size and you can see it it's
n by k by
d and you're going to
take um
you're going to take the queries uh it's
going to get complicated
so you're going to take the queries
over here and
you're going to compute the output yp
which is going to be n
by d
yes this is n this is n you're going to
do it once per
and then you're going to add the y's
together
so this is a plus for the final y
so you can see these are two completely
linear uh this is
y c the content y
two completely linearly separable
pathways one comes from these positional
codings and one comes from these
from the context and the positional
encodings are actually more important
in the experiments if they leave those
away nothing works if they leave this
summarizing away then stuff pretty much
works
still so you know
um it's fair to say that the power here
comes from the
positional encodings and that
again a bit it's a bit counter to their
to their narrative because i feel
the the whole point of the lambda layers
is to do this stuff
right here and this here is something
that you need to make it work
but in any case what you do is you take
you take these positional encodings and
you multiply them by
the values so what this does
is this here this is a special object
this lambda p as you can see it creates
n times k times d tensor
and this is it's a big tensor so what
does it do
for each of the n
pieces in the input for each of the end
pieces in the input
it creates a one of these lists right
one of these
k sized lists k size list of d
vectors as we've seen before but it does
so
differently for each position okay
so for each position it creates a
different table and
the queue again indexes into this
table but into you know at the position
where it is so
if you take the query from
a particular position in the output it's
going to look to its
table aggregate it according to
what it's interested in so the the
positional encodings basically say
if you if if if this
element in the context if you
are the first element in the sequence
then you have to aggregate information
according to
this particular scheme but if you're the
second element
you have to aggregate information
according to this particular scheme
so again it can't look at the contents
of what these
particular things are it can only
kind of define a linear operation
however it can kind of look at the
contents of the query
because usually x and c are the same
so by incorporating v in here
m being equal to n most often it can
actually do that and again we see in the
results that most of the information
actually goes
through this path the good thing
again is that so here you have
n by m but you don't have a b you don't
have a batch size
here the batch size appears because
there is actually a batch size
right there is a batch size here
and then the batch size would appear
right here but at the moment the batch
size appears
the n by m term falls away so there is
no
m right here you contract over m as you
introduce the batch size
so again there is nowhere an n by m
tensor to be held
um as you at that that is scaled by the
batch size
so there is again this this kind of
performance increase
but you can already see here you have we
we have these nice construction where oh
the whole context constructs this table
of vectors and then the query aggregates
it
and here we construct a
separate table for each element in the
input
and then the query according to its
position aggregates that and it simply
adds those two
aggregations together most of the
performance comes from the
bottom right here which you can sort of
see this as uh if you know if you have
like y
equals w x plus b you can sort of see
the w here
uh as these tables right here because
they actually depend on what the x is in
this case
the position of the x and the b is just
something that
comes on top to every single position
that um that there is okay
this is a giant mess but that's about
how it works and i hope you didn't
you didn't completely you didn't get
completely lost
in this so they
have a whole bunch of extensions as i
said so they have
translation equivariance then because
they build their positional encodings
as relative encodings
which makes it very easy to then build
this
lambda convolution so you can actually
implement
this operation here as a convolutional
operation to get this positional lambda
and their whole point is kind of that if
i do local attention
right if i do local attention what i
need to do
is i kind of um if i do local attention
then this thing only pays attention to
these three and this thing only pays
attention to these three
kind of like a convolution but because
it's an attention
for each of these things i need to build
my attention map
i need to build my attention map and
that kind of if i want to batch this if
i want to do this
at once i need to sort of
if this is my interaction matrix it kind
of looks like this
this downward descending stairs or
something like this
and that is not well supported in
current frameworks
and that makes it a lot like really slow
they say look even though we use the
same amount of let's say memory
as local attention or or time sorry time
we can implement it using these
primitives and they are much faster
so they are they're going to outperform
local attention
in that sense they do compare here in
terms of
time and space to an attention layer now
they split this into content
interactions which is that first pathway
and position interactions
like this here this is absolutely
irrelevant
because um it's smaller than the
position interaction and the position
interactions give the
performance so you can see
clearly that there is uh
in space we have b times n times
m h is the number of heads so we don't
even care much about that
right now so b times n times for the
attention layer which is the problem
and here you see you have n times m here
but no b and you have b times n
but no m so that is kind of the the gain
right here
as long as you can keep the k small
right this intermediate sequence which
makes sense
right this attention goes to this
intermediate sequence
so as long as you can keep that
intermediate sequence small and fixed
you don't have a problem with this
quadratic
memory at least you have a problem right
here but that's not modulated by the
batch size
in terms of time it's still um
you can see there is a b times n times m
you still have that time complexity
because after all you need to do these
multiplications and and contracts just
the same
so not much of a difference in terms of
time
the time argument is more like they can
implement it using
convolutional operators rather than the
this kind of striding
attention maps they also do this in
multi-query
mult like multi-head and so on and you
can see right here
that um
where it outperforms it outperforms
other systems including
like systems with self-attention
especially
in terms of if you see the memory if you
do global self-attention
it uses a lot of memory in fact like an
out-of-memory error on their
machine axial self-attention these are
all kind of limits to self-attention
local self-attention which comes closest
to
what they do but then what you suffer is
a massive drop in performance whereas
their
lambda layer right here
it has a lot of performance and you can
see
the performance gain right this is k i
believe k
is equal to 16 in this example if they
go
k to 8 and we know that the attention
interaction in the lambda
networks is not n by m but actually
m by k so if you have k you can already
see there is a massive jump
in the number of examples you can
throughput
through the network okay so
um that kind of gives evidence to
what we are well what my hypothesis is
is going on right here okay
lastly i've already shown you this table
as it outperforms kind of the the
efficient nets and this is a special
version of lambda networks the lambda
res nets where they take resnets and
they only
uh they only replace a part
of the resnet so if you look at the
table down here
these are the different architectures
where they could replace
things in the resnet for example the
resnet 50 right here
so this is all convolutions this is kind
of the baseline and you can see
that it's like 7 200 samples per second
if you replace everything by a lambda
layer
you're down to like 1 160 examples per
second
interestingly if you replace the first
layer by a lambda layer
you are also the performance drops
enormously and and that is because of
course the
the sizes of the of the of the images
get smaller and smaller so
your n gets smaller and smaller as you
go up the layers
as you can see right here if you only
replace the last
layer by a lambda layer then you can
gain all back almost all of that
performance and
interestingly still outperform the
complete
convolutional layer
and it also has less parameters you can
see
the 25 instead of the the 18.
all right so that was my rant on this
paper
again i hope this wasn't too convoluted
there's a lot more to this paper
um i want to kind of quickly shout out
lucid reigns and uh
made a made a i gotta show you
this is hilarious implement he
implemented
uh this so
yes thank you
implemented this as the paper came out
and of course
well we don't know if phil wang
is the author of this paper
we we don't know maybe maybe not um
chances are not but still cool that he
goes ahead and
implements these things i especially i
love
the conciseness using the inops right
here so there
are as you can see like this is it
that's it
that's all uh the the use of inops right
here to like do this rearrange and
iron some operations which are much more
concise than the
kind of reshape um squeeze on squeeze
whatnot
so that's pretty cool and the coolest
thing is
lambda actual greek letters in the code
thank you python
uh so yeah i i invite you to check out
uh this implementation i'll of course
link it tell me what you think of the
paper
and i'll see you next time bye